but this is when we think about uh
direction and magnitude
or if you'd like to think about it that
way in polar form right that's the
direction of magnitude gives you
we also need to know how to calculate
this in component form right component
form
now you may remember or maybe you just
have in your book
what the definition definition is in 2d
what the formula is
in 2d for the dot product in 2d but what
i want to actually do is
prove it for you okay how can we prove
that
this is going to give you this object
over here which you could more or less
guess
based on what it looks like in 2d but
how can we actually establish
that fact so here's what i'd like you to
do draw with me a diagram that's going
to have some arbitrary a
and some arbitrary b and i'm going to
give you sort of a
two to three minute head start because
you did this proof in the opposite
direction
within extension one most likely okay
coming from component form
and then using which trigonometric rule
do you think was handy to come up with
this definition
the cosine rule right you use the cosine
rule
in a triangle to get from the component
form definition
over to this one could you draw a
diagram that would help you go in the
opposite direction remember it's just
really thinking in
back in two dimensions okay let me give
you a bit of a head start i will draw a
diagram on the board that
will begin not very helpfully but
hopefully it will be a foundation for
you
okay have a go and then in two three
minutes i'll show you how i'm gonna do
it okay
get started uh let me see
if i can give you a little bit of a hand
and please at the point at which you're
like oh now i see where to go
right abandon me like you you don't need
to go as slow as i do to get to the full
proof
what i'm going to try and get to is from
this definition
which comes from what i want the dot
product to mean
and this diagram i'm going to add some
things onto this diagram which will help
me get to
well how do i work it out if for example
i don't know
what that angle theta is between the two
right that's quite a tricky thing to do
we can do it just out of my my x's my
y's and my z's my coordinates here's how
i'm going to do it
i've begun my diagram with my a and b by
the way of course
our a and our b
may not actually be together right they
just could be anywhere
but in order to consider the dot product
we want to know what the angle is
between them so we just put their
tails together remember that because
that's why the diagram looks the way
that it does
now why have i added in this red vector
what's the red vector called by the way
on my scheme what would you call that
red vector
you could call it the resultant vector
after putting uh these two things
together but in a careful way
i guess the label would just be a b
right so i could i could call it that
which i might just do a
b and the reason why it's helpful to me
because i saw it on like
two-thirds of your diagrams but not
everyone's is because if i'm going to
use the cosine rule
the cosine rule relates three sides
the three lengths of those sides in a
triangle together do you agree with that
so therefore i need to form a triangle
with my two vectors
now i don't know the magnitude of a b i
don't yet
okay but i i can get it in terms of a
and b
now maybe you already are like i know
what to write in there but if you're
looking at that geometrically and
thinking
i'm not sure how i would get to this
thing over here
think about how we've gotten a
from an origin right maybe i should
label that there for you call this oa
and call this ob how would i create this
vector what would i
do have a think
now for me there's um there's some
constructions missing there's a
parallelogram always hiding where you've
got two vectors
going on right so for instance i could
say
let's put on here think about the best
way to do this i'm going to put it on
here
if i put that vector over there that
dotted one right
on the base of the information that i've
provided to you what would be the value
or the label for that vector over there
look where i've constructed it yeah it's
gonna be negative a right
uh same magnitude but opposite direction
do you agree
so negative a like so
now the reason why that's helpful is
because i can then say if i start from o
go to b and then follow whatever this
vector is negative a
then that gives me this resultant vector
do you agree but look at the red vector
a b that i wanted
and this new dotted line red vector that
i've just drawn
clearly they're the same vector right
they're not in the same position but
displacement wise they're doing the same
thing it's the whole point of the
parallelogram law yeah
so therefore i can say well this is also
a b just in a different spot it's o
whatever you call this c or something
like that okay but for my purposes
i just want a magnitude i just want a
magnitude so therefore i can say these
two
magnitudes are going to be the same
because opposite sides in a
parallelogram
are equal i could call it the magnitude
of b
minus a but just to be convenient for my
algebra later on i'm going to call it
the magnitude of
a minus b because when you take the
magnitude it's going to be the same
whichever direction you're looking in do
you agree with that
i could just point the arrow in the
opposite direction and you get the same
deal okay
so now how do i get from here to
something relating
all of the components well let's just go
ahead and write and come back to this
now
let's just go ahead and write what the
cosine rule looks like what it tells us
about
the sides and the angle in this triangle
have a think with me right how would you
normally write the cosine rule
what's it normally look like
c squared equals you could start with
cos theta you could start there's lots
of different perspectives which are all
equally valid but in our case
i guess i'd probably say c squared this
is like the side opposite
the angle that i have because i only
have one angle c squared equals
a squared plus b squared minus
2 a b cos c and i like it that way
because it's closest to pythagoras
theorem which is what cosine rule is
right
now let's write that c squared a squared
and so on in the context of this
right so i guess i would write be
careful here right
uh a b right its magnitude
squared there's my c squared okay with
that
that equals two i'm gonna do the rest of
the cosine rule now i've got this side
and this side over here so they would be
the magnitude of
o a squared then i've got
i don't know my squared is so high up
there i've got the magnitude of o
b also squared and then what comes next
this last part
minus two my two my two sides that
include the angle which in this case are
away and ob
and then the bit that gives the cosine
rule it's name
because of the included angle which i've
just conveniently called theta so far so
good
okay so i've got all the magnitudes
there but now let's turn it into
like how can i get to this
from this rather to this right to
component form what's the expressions
for all of these things so
i'm going to turn this into my vector
notation so i've got
let's see here this one here is a minus
b i think is what i called it
that okay little a little b squared
this one's just little a squared
little b squared sort of go on from here
to little a little b
cos theta but now i want you to go back
to our very first
lesson this is how we're going to get to
component form right our very first
lesson in 3d
vectors we use pythagoras to work out a
distance formula right that's that's all
this thing is
what is the distance between two
arbitrary vectors
with different coordinates i'll give you
a clue
there's a lot of things that are squared
think about pythagoras theorem do you
remember didn't have
pythagorean triples it had a pythagorean
quadruple right there were three here
and then there was one on the other side
okay what's it going to look like you've
got to compare components right
x components compare those
remember we divide it up into our x
direction then we do it for our y
direction
like so then we do it in our z direction
if you pop the square root over the
whole thing that's just your distance
formula right but i don't need to do
that
because i'm actually squared up here
what's that equal to
how do we work out the distance of or
the magnitude rather of just a single
vector
it's the same thing again isn't it it's
just that each of these is going to be
0 because i'm comparing to the origin
right so this is going to be
take a breath x a
squared plus y b y a squared sorry
getting my letters mixed up z a squared
that's what i get from
here i'm going to have to just rehearse
the whole thing
for b so i'm going to get x b
squared y b squared
and z b squared
minus two lots of and then i'm going to
have to
complete this right you see this here
now
think about this pause for a moment
before you keep on writing
i've been turning as much as i can of
this cosine rule into component form
component form right i'm not going to do
it to this last bit
i'm not going to turn the 2 a b cos
theta into component form can anyone
tell me why
because that's actually the thing that i
wanted remember it's like oh good
if i can find out what this is equal to
and all the components will be on the
other side
then i'm done so don't get rid of that
thing that's pretty much already in the
form that i wanted
happy so i'm going to write just to a
b whoops cos theta okay
now there's a little bit of algebra to
do here so i'm going to pause and let
you try and take
over from here i know it looks long and
awkward but actually it's quite routine
once you get in the rhythm of expanding
all the things
cancelling all things can you see how
very many things are going to cancel
so let me give you 10 15 seconds i know
i've written a lot of stuff on the board
just to catch up and then i'll show you
what this is going to look like and what
will cancel
okay so what i've done is two things
number one we'll start with the right
hand side because it's actually easier
on the right hand side i actually have
not changed anything but i've just
color-coded
my x's and my y's and my zeds is that
okay because i know on the left-hand
side when i expand and this is the
second thing i do
when i expand this garbled mess i'm
gonna get these same terms
an x a squared and x b squared from
these binomial expansions
over here so now we're just going to
have fun
cancelling are you ready okay cancel
cancel
cancel cancel you can see i've done it
with the colors to make it easier for
you
my y's cancel
here go the z's being a bit lazy there
okay so what do we get left with we can
even cancel a little bit further can't
we because there is now
looking at the three terms left over
here and the one term left over there's
a common factor on the left hand side
and right hand side namely
negative two right so let's uh get rid
of all those negative twos which means i
get rid of
this negative two and what you get left
with on the right hand side is how we
by definition describes the dot product
right in three dimensions just like in
two dimensions so
i can just replace the right hand side
with a right on the left just for
convenience
a dot b right
and i just get what's left on the left
hand side which can you see the
extension from the dot product formula
from 2d right let me just cover this
green bit here there it is right there
x a x b plus y a y b
right there it is in 2d now we're in 3d
right so let's just go ahead and write
that
x a x b multiply your x's
multiply your y's and multiply
your z's and you're there so this
this is our formula in component form it
is essential
the syllabus tells us you can't just um
use it you also need to know
where it comes from right and be able to
go in both directions